you know I do have to ask you Sarah
Jessica Parker recently said that Kerry
should have ended up with big but anyone
who ended up with Aden would be a lucky
girl and then she praised you as an
actor I feel like I got to know Kerry
Kerry but it was like to mess around
before she arrived at that I'm curious
if you agree yeah how do you react to
that first of all well she's always been
so kind to me anytime anybody asks her a
question about me I'm always blown away
by a nice she is I mean I can see us
friends so it's reciprocated
I have always nice things to say about
her but how do I feel about big Carrie
and big should have ended up together or
do you think it should have been aided
well selfishly I like to win
my characters like to win but know
there's no other way for that formula to
to go down except with mr. big it would
have been a good show if she ended up
with this guy there's a lot of fans who
might disagree with that statement
though that's just because I'm charming
and I got a good head air
I mean you do have good hair before I
let you go how do you celebrate
Valentine's Day with Bo like what do you
guys do we go to dinner if we can get a
place that's not too crowded
you know you're like oh we only have a
5:15 table left but you know we live in
a small town so sometimes we can pop in
there yeah that's usually a dinner thing
it's some dinner and little champagne
and we got 20 years now it's 20 years is
the secret after 20 years not like a
lifetime you want all the secrets going
back to the listening listening doesn't
hurt to really hear somebody that you're
living with instead of tuning about who
she really listens to me and you know by
that I mean she listens to what I'm
saying and watching what I'm doing and
she's you know she's just president
she's in the moment if the cliche saying
goes but yeah that's it I think just
listening to each other who's more
romantic you or dr. Covey oh definitely
dr. Covey I promise I am NOT going to
break your heart
I promise not to waste your hurt I feel
like dr. Covey is such an amazing dad to
his three girls right like what do you
hope other parents can learn from his
parenting style know it's funny I play a
guy who's got kids sometimes in movies
these days and I don't have any kids
surrounded by lots of people for decades
now that are always having babies and
I'm around little kids a lot so I see
what goes into it I don't know he just
seems to listen to them I think that's
always a good thing to do is the parent
really put your ears on
[Music]